This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every game from rock paper scissors to tennis to Mario Kart is a design system. I like to think of game design as a design discipline that is sort of shoulder to shoulder with other design fields like graphic design or architecture or industrial design.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。从石头剪刀布到网球，再到马里奥赛车，每一款游戏都是一个设计系统。我喜欢把游戏设计看作是一门设计学科，它与平面设计、建筑设计或工业设计等其他设计领域并驾齐驱。
This is Eric Zimmerman. I work at the NYU Game Center, and I'm actually a professor of game design, if you can believe it. The raw materials that game designers work with are the rules. What game designers do, in essence, is create the rules of the game.
我是埃里克·齐默尔曼。我在纽约大学游戏中心工作，如果你敢相信的话，我其实是一位游戏设计教授。游戏设计师使用的原材料就是规则。从本质上讲，游戏设计师所做的就是创造游戏的规则。
But when players enter into the system of the game and decide to follow the rules, what results is play, and play is the opposite of rules. So while rules are fixed and rigid and logical, play is improvisational and creative and spontaneous, and that's such an amazing, weird little paradox of games. The goal of good game design is what Eric calls meaningful play. And it's sort of a shorthand for making sure that you're taking care of your players. Ensuring that players stay engaged and that their actions have consequences.
但是，当玩家进入游戏系统并决定遵守规则时，产生的结果就是“游玩”（play），而“游玩”与规则恰恰相反。因此，虽然规则是固定、僵化且合乎逻辑的，但“游玩”却是即兴、创造性和自发的，这就是游戏一个奇妙而怪异的悖论。优秀游戏设计的目标是埃里克所说的“有意义的游玩”。这是一种简写，旨在确保你照顾好你的玩家。确保玩家保持参与感，并且他们的行为会产生后果。
All of that makes sense. That's Blake Eskin. He makes the Observatory Podcast for a design observer. But there's one game. It's a really popular one. And when I play it, I don't feel taken care of as a player. I feel bored. I feel trapped.
这一切都说得通。那是布莱克·埃斯金。他为《设计观察者》制作了《天文台播客》。但有一款游戏，它非常受欢迎。当我玩它时，我并没有感到作为玩家被照顾到。我感到无聊。我感到被困住了。
I feel like it's never going to end. Here I go. Monopoly. One, two, three, four, five, six. Whoa! I've got some money. You get some money. I get some money you get some money You are a race car or a hat or an iron or a scutty dog
我觉得它永远不会结束。我要开始了。大富翁。一、二、三、四、五、六。哇！我拿到钱了。你拿到钱了。我拿到钱了，你拿到钱了。你是一个赛车、帽子、熨斗或苏格兰梗犬。
You're circling around and around the board passing go collecting $200 fine property Having to pay when you land on someone else's property. Building houses. Passing go again. Circling again. Oh no! That's usually the critique of monopoly. That it's very, very slow and long. And it ends up being this very gradual slog where one player gradually survives the others as, you know,
你绕着棋盘转了一圈又一圈，经过起点领取200美元，缴纳罚款，在落到别人的房产上时必须支付费用。盖房子。再次经过起点。再次绕圈。噢，不！这通常是对《大富翁》的批评。它非常、非常缓慢且漫长。最终变成了一种非常缓慢的苦差事，其中一名玩家逐渐熬过其他人，正如你所知，
everyone is bleed it out for money from each other. Exactly. No way! Here's Louis CK, talking about playing the game with his kids. The monopoly loss is dark. It's heavy. When she loses it, monopoly, I gotta look at her little face and I go, okay, so here's what's
每个人都在互相榨取钱财。没错。没门！这是路易·CK在谈论和孩子们玩这个游戏。大富翁的失败是黑暗的。它是沉重的。当她输掉大富翁时，我得看着她的小脸，我说，好吧，那么现在会发生什么，好吗？你所有的财产，你拥有的一切。所有的铁路、你的房子、你所有的钱。现在都是我的了。大富翁可能很慢。正如路易·CK所说，失败可能是黑暗的。然而，这款游戏却非常受欢迎。它打破了所有这些经典的好设计规则，但方式非常有趣。
gonna happen now, okay? All your property, everything you have. All the railroads, your houses, all your money. That's mine now. Monopoly can be slow. The losses as Louis C. Cape went out can be dark. And yet, the game is incredibly popular. It breaks all of these classic rules of good design, but in very interesting ways.
（注：原文第7段与第6段内容有重叠，此处按要求翻译）大富翁可能很慢。正如路易·CK所说，失败可能是黑暗的。然而，这款游戏却非常受欢迎。它打破了所有这些经典的好设计规则，但方式非常有趣。
When monopoly was created, it wasn't supposed to teach children to be ruthless capitalists. In fact, it was just the opposite. It became the embodiment of everything that it originally set out to critique. And I think that's maybe part of the fascination of monopoly, maybe buried inside this capitalist fantasy are somehow the seeds of its opposite hidden there somewhere within the design. The game we call monopoly goes back to the gilded age, a time of great prosperity in America, at least for the carneggies and the Rockefellers.
当《大富翁》被创造出来时，它本意并不是要教孩子们成为冷酷的资本家。事实上，恰恰相反。它成为了它最初试图批判的一切的化身。我认为这也许是《大富翁》魅力的一部分，也许埋藏在这个资本主义幻想中的，正是其对立面的种子，以某种方式隐藏在设计之中。我们称之为《大富翁》的游戏可以追溯到镀金时代，那是美国繁荣昌盛的时期，至少对于卡内基和洛克菲勒家族来说是这样。
The rest of the country was not doing so well. Income inequality was growing. But an economist named Henry George thought he had a solution. Henry George proposed a single tax theory, which would completely upend the American capitalist system as we know it. Land ownership would be abolished. Instead, all land would be public property. Individuals and companies would rent land, and that rent would get taxed, and this in theory would create an economy where wealth is distributed more fairly. The theory is much more complicated
全国其他地区的情况并不那么好。收入不平等正在加剧。但一位名叫亨利·乔治的经济学家认为他找到了解决方案。亨利·乔治提出了单一税理论，这将彻底颠覆我们所知的美国资本主义制度。土地所有权将被废除。相反，所有土地都将成为公共财产。个人和公司将租赁土地，而租金将被征税，从理论上讲，这将创造一个财富分配更公平的经济。这个理论比这复杂得多，
than that, but that's all you're going to get from me. Go listen to plan and money or something. This single-tax theory gained a lot of followers, including one woman named Lizzy McGee. Lizzy McGee was a woman who I consider you very before her time. That's Mary Pilon, author of The Monopolis, Obsession, Fury, and the scandal behind the world's favorite board game. The story that starts with Lizzy McGee. Lizzy McGee decided to spread the word about single-tax theory. In 1904, she patented a board game that she called the Landlord's Game. Landlords at the time were considered to be bad people.
但你从我这里只能得到这些。去听《计划与金钱》之类的节目吧。这个单一税理论获得了许多追随者，其中包括一位名叫莉齐·麦吉的女性。莉齐·麦吉是一位我认为非常超前于她那个时代的女性。那是玛丽·皮隆，她是《大富翁：痴迷、狂热以及这款世界最受欢迎棋盘游戏背后的丑闻》的作者。故事始于莉齐·麦吉。莉齐·麦吉决定传播单一税理论。1904年，她为一款她称之为《地主游戏》的棋盘游戏申请了专利。当时的地主被认为是坏人。
McGee took a white square board, labeled one corner go to jail, another one she labeled Public Park, and the rest of it was rimmed with rectangular spaces that players could rent or buy. There were no colors, no graphics, just black rectangles and writing on a whiteboard. Players rolled dice and circled the board, buying up properties and railroads, collecting money and paying rent.
麦吉拿了一个白色方形棋盘，在一个角落贴上“进监狱”，另一个角落贴上“公园”，其余部分则环绕着矩形空间，玩家可以租赁或购买。没有颜色，没有图形，只有黑色矩形和白板上的文字。玩家掷骰子绕着棋盘走，购买房产和铁路，收集金钱并支付租金。
Players who ran out of money were sent to the poor house. Players who trespassed on land were sent to jail. And she created two rule sets. There was a monopolist rule set and then a single tax rule set. If you played with the single tax rules, when one player develops property, everyone benefits. But in the monopolist rules, the goal was to create monopolies and crush each other.
钱花光的玩家被送进贫民窟。擅自闯入土地的玩家被送进监狱。她创建了两套规则。一套是垄断规则，另一套是单一税规则。如果你用单一税规则玩，当一个玩家开发房产时，每个人都会受益。但在垄断规则中，目标是制造垄断并互相压垮。
The hope was you'd play with both sets of rules. See the differences and come away totally sold on the single tax theory. The more vise-laden one clearly has taken off ironically enough. Of course everyone preferred the monopolist's rules set because in a board game being evil is fun. And the landlord's game had a greater capacity for evil than most board games at the time. If you look at games that are like late, very end of 19th century, early 20th century
希望是你两套规则都玩。看看其中的差异，然后完全被单一税理论所说服。讽刺的是，那个充满恶意的版本显然更受欢迎。当然，每个人都更喜欢垄断规则，因为在棋盘游戏中变坏很有趣。而且《地主游戏》比当时大多数棋盘游戏具有更大的作恶能力。如果你看看19世纪末、20世纪初的游戏，
games, there's not a lot of depth to them. They're mostly games where you're just kind of moving characters along a track, rolling a die. And I think in that context, the Landlords game probably stuck out as something really interesting, weird, different, and innovative. The Landlords game made its way around the northeast, to college campuses and activist circles. Folk variations organically popped up in different cities, and properties on the board would be named after real streets and locations. And around the time of the Depression, a man named Charles
它们没有太多的深度。它们大多是那种你只是沿着轨道移动角色、掷骰子的游戏。我认为在这种背景下，《地主游戏》可能显得非常有趣、怪异、与众不同且具有创新性。《地主游戏》在东北部流传开来，进入了大学校园和活动家圈子。民间变体在不同城市有机地涌现，棋盘上的房产以真实的街道和地点命名。在大萧条时期前后，一个名叫查尔斯·达罗的人
Darrow stumbled upon a version of the Landlords game that was made in a Quaker community, in Atlantic City, New Jersey. It featured locations like Marvin Gardens and Vermont Avenue and the Boardwalk. Daryl basically now the Quaker version of the Landlord's game and started to tweak it into a board game that he would sell himself. He called it Monopoly. Daryl, my reporting is yielded that he was in fact unemployed at the time. He was in fact living in the Philadelphia area, and this game made him enormously successful.
偶然发现了一个在新泽西州大西洋城的一个贵格会社区制作的《地主游戏》版本。它以马文花园、佛蒙特大道和木板路等地点为特色。达罗基本上拿走了贵格会版本的《地主游戏》，并开始对其进行调整，将其变成他自己销售的棋盘游戏。他称之为《大富翁》。达罗，我的报道显示他当时确实失业了。他确实住在费城地区，而这款游戏让他获得了巨大的成功。
Darrow made one game a day by hand. He sold them out of his home for $4 a piece. He used bright cheap paint, and he misspelled a few of the locations in Atlantic City. And yes, he totally stole the concept. The look of Dero's game was pretty much the landlord's game, but Dero improved the graphics and added some color. There's a kind of graphic clarity to Monopoly that's really satisfying, and the game started selling like hotcakes, maybe because it was really fun to handle all of that fake money, especially during the Depression. And then Monopoly attracts the attention of a family-owned company called Parker Brothers. They buy the Dero game and they buy his leftover stock.
达罗每天手工制作一款游戏。他以每款4美元的价格在家里卖掉它们。他使用了明亮廉价的油漆，并且拼错了大西洋城的几个地点。是的，他完全窃取了这个概念。达罗游戏的外观几乎就是《地主游戏》，但达罗改进了图形并添加了一些颜色。《大富翁》有一种非常令人满意的图形清晰度，游戏开始像热卖品一样销售，也许是因为在经济大萧条时期，处理所有那些假钱真的很有趣。然后《大富翁》引起了一家名为帕克兄弟的家族企业的注意。他们买下了达罗的游戏，并买下了他剩下的库存。
It saves the firm from the brink of destruction. But Parker Brothers wasn't pleased when they learned that Dero had not actually invented Monopoly. So they start to stamp out all the different versions of Lizzie McGee's game and finally they buy her patent. Lizzie McGee, as best as we know, got $500 for creating, you know, the landlord's game, which is I consider to be the foundation of Monopoly. Monopoly then becomes the sole property of Parker Brothers, and for years Parker Brothers perpetuates the myth that Darrow just invented the game out of whole cloth. Monopoly made a lot of money for Parker Brothers.
这使公司免于毁灭的边缘。但当帕克兄弟得知达罗并没有真正发明《大富翁》时，他们并不高兴。于是他们开始清除莉齐·麦吉游戏的所有不同版本，最终买下了她的专利。据我们所知，莉齐·麦吉因创造了《地主游戏》获得了500美元，我认为这是《大富翁》的基础。《大富翁》随后成为帕克兄弟的独家财产，多年来，帕克兄弟一直宣扬达罗凭空发明了这款游戏的谎言。《大富翁》为帕克兄弟赚了很多钱。
They eventually got acquired by Hasbro. And of course today Monopoly made a lot of money for Parker Brothers. They eventually got acquired by Hasbro. And of course today Monopoly is everywhere. There are hundreds of variations on the game, international competitions, that McDonald's promotion, and all kinds of shirts and mugs and neckties printed with Monopoly graphics. But just because people buy it doesn't mean they play it. I think that people buy Monopoly not just certainly to play it as a great game, but because it's monopoly and it's something you have in your closet and it's something you should have. To me, monopoly feels like a cheesy Christmas album
他们最终被孩之宝收购。当然，今天《大富翁》到处都是。游戏有数百种变体、国际比赛、麦当劳的促销活动，以及印有《大富翁》图形的各种衬衫、马克杯和领带。但仅仅因为人们购买它并不意味着他们会玩它。我认为人们购买《大富翁》不仅仅是为了把它当作一款伟大的游戏来玩，而是因为它就是《大富翁》，它是你衣柜里应该有的东西。对我来说，《大富翁》感觉就像一张俗气的圣诞专辑，
like Bing Crosby or something where it's not something that you would normally listen to, but it's kind of something that you might drag out in an ironic way or in a nostalgic way. And that nostalgia feeds itself. Then you have parents with kids that are getting nostalgic about the games that they played and they want to introduce those games to their children and play them again. In other words, Monopoly isn't popular because it's a great game.
比如平·克劳斯贝之类的，它不是你通常会听的东西，但它是一种你可能会以讽刺或怀旧的方式拿出来的东西。而这种怀旧情绪会自我滋养。然后你有带着孩子的父母，他们对玩过的游戏感到怀旧，他们想把这些游戏介绍给他们的孩子并再次玩它们。换句话说，《大富翁》受欢迎并不是因为它是一款伟大的游戏。
It's only popular now because it was popular then. And we don't even play by the real rules. Well, nobody plays right to begin with. How many people have actually read the rule set that comes in a commercial and monopoly set? For example, the way most people play if you land on an available property that you don't want to buy or can't afford,
它现在受欢迎只是因为它当时受欢迎。而且我们甚至不按真正的规则玩。好吧，一开始就没有人玩得对。有多少人真正读过商业版《大富翁》套装里的规则集？例如，大多数人的玩法是，如果你落在一个你不想买或买不起的可用房产上，
nothing happens. And that is technically wrong. According to the directions, if you land on an available property that you don't want, or can't afford, it gets auctioned off. This could make the game way more exciting, though not necessarily faster. If you can imagine every turn, it's not like a quick decision do I buy this or not, it's like, let's start an auction.
什么都不会发生。这在技术上是错误的。根据说明，如果你落在一个你不想买或买不起的可用房产上，它会被拍卖。这可能会让游戏变得更有趣，尽管不一定会更快。如果你能想象每一回合，这不像是一个简单的决定“我买还是不买”，而是“让我们开始拍卖吧”。
What do you think? Well, let's auction this and who's going to bid higher? And so, it drags out the game. But Eric is reluctant to accuse anyone of playing Monopoly wrong. The way we play Monopoly, even all the cheating that happens, Monopoly is notorious for people cheating and hiding money and taking money from the bank
你觉得呢？好吧，让我们拍卖这个，谁出价更高？所以，这拖慢了游戏节奏。但埃里克不愿指责任何人玩《大富翁》的方式不对。我们玩《大富翁》的方式，即使是所有发生的作弊行为，大富翁也以人们作弊、藏钱和从银行拿钱而闻名，
and things like that. I mean, that is Monopoly, right? Monopoly is not just a set of rules. Monopoly is all of the cultural meaning and all the ways that we play it and all of the ways that we play it and all of the ways that we use and misuse the game. And this is why some game designers defend Monopoly. The game designer Richard Garfield, he's a brilliant game designer, he invented
诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这就是《大富翁》，对吧？《大富翁》不仅仅是一套规则。《大富翁》是所有的文化意义，是我们玩它的所有方式，以及我们使用和滥用游戏的所有方式。这就是为什么一些游戏设计师为《大富翁》辩护。游戏设计师理查德·加菲尔德，他是一位出色的游戏设计师，他发明了
collectible card games with Magic the Gathering. I've heard him defend Monopoly and say there's some things about Monopoly that are actually kind of interesting. I was at a convention and came back and my son told me that he had played Monopoly for the first time with a sister and that they really enjoyed the game. That's the legend himself, Richard Garfield. I said, oh, that's great. How many times do you play and who won? And he looked at me with a screened look and as I said, oh, that's great. How many times do you play and who won?
《万智牌》等集换式卡牌游戏。我听过他为《大富翁》辩护，说《大富翁》中确实有一些东西非常有趣。我在参加一个会议回来后，我儿子告诉我他第一次和姐姐玩了《大富翁》，他们真的很喜欢这个游戏。那是传奇人物理查德·加菲尔德。我说，哦，那太棒了。你们玩了几次，谁赢了？他用一种困惑的眼神看着我，正如我说，哦，那太棒了。你们玩了几次，谁赢了？
And he looked at me with a screen looking as I said, oh, you don't win, monopoly. You just play it. They're not as much about the rank at the end. If you're having fun doing the process of play for a lot of kids, that's a game. So for kids, meaningful play in monopoly comes when the game is treated less like playing chess and more like playing house. Collecting properties is a good thing, getting money is a good thing.
他用一种困惑的眼神看着我，正如我说，哦，你不会赢《大富翁》。你只是在玩它。它们并不那么看重最终的排名。如果你在游玩的过程中玩得很开心，对很多孩子来说，那就是游戏。所以对孩子们来说，《大富翁》中“有意义的游玩”来自于把游戏看得不像下棋，而更像是过家家。收集房产是好事，得到钱是好事。
Being the study dogs is a good thing, but not going to jail is a good thing, but there's not necessarily an end to it all. It's just your following rules and making decisions and accumulating good and bad things. For me, this was a total revelation. I think there may be something to that, but I have to say, I played Monopoly for the first time with my boys recently, and they were totally in it to win it. Carver crushed us all. And when we went bankrupt, he would continue to give us little bits of money just so we
当苏格兰梗犬是好事，不进监狱是好事，但这一切并不一定有终点。你只是在遵守规则、做出决定并积累好坏事物。对我来说，这完全是一个启示。我想这其中可能有些道理，但我必须说，我最近第一次和我的孩子们玩了《大富翁》，他们完全是为了赢。卡弗压垮了我们所有人。当我们破产时，他会继续给我们一点点钱，只是为了让我们
would stay in the game and he could crush us all over again. He was exactly the kind of capitalist that Lizzy McGee was trying to warn us about. And he loved it. My favorite part of my napily is taking money from my brother when I made huge hotels. I really like annoying my brother. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Blake Eskin and Avery Truffleman as the Iron. With Sam Greenspan as the Hat, Katie Mingle as the Scotty Dog and Game Winner Kurt Colestead as the Wheelbarrow. Also playing with Morgan Dewey as my favorite, the race car. Eric Zimmerman co-wrote a handbook on game design called Rules of Play.
留在游戏中，这样他就可以再次压垮我们所有人。他正是莉齐·麦吉试图警告我们的那种资本家。他很喜欢这样。我玩《大富翁》最喜欢的部分是从我哥哥那里拿钱，当我盖了巨大的酒店时。我真的很喜欢惹恼我哥哥。《99%隐形》本周由布莱克·埃斯金和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，他们是熨斗。萨姆·格林斯潘是帽子，凯蒂·明格尔是苏格兰梗犬，游戏赢家库尔特·科尔斯特德是独轮手推车。还有摩根·杜威扮演我最喜欢的赛车。埃里克·齐默尔曼合著了一本名为《游玩规则》的游戏设计手册。
In it, he and Katie sailin tell you pretty much everything you need to design a good game, and you can easily take those tools to design a good anything. Special thanks this week to Emily Kwong and Jesse Fuchs, Matt Foreback, Sophie Belkin, Sessler, and everyone at the NYU Game Center. We are a project of 91.7KAL, W and San Francisco, and produced at the offices of Arxan, an architecture and interiors firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links
在书中，他和凯蒂·萨林告诉你设计一款好游戏所需的一切，你可以很容易地利用这些工具来设计任何好东西。本周特别感谢艾米丽·邝和杰西·福克斯、马特·福巴克、苏菲·贝尔金、塞斯勒以及纽约大学游戏中心的所有人。我们是91.7KALW旧金山的一个项目，在旧金山美丽的市中心奥克兰的建筑和室内设计公司Arxan的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的图片和链接，
and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99i.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集。你必须访问99i.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。